it's a Tuesday afternoon addition to the
PFT p.m. podcast and look who we have
here from his home somewhere in an
undisclosed location in New England
Massachusetts Rhode Island Connecticut
where where do you live where are you
I'm in Massachusetts town called
Freetown Massachusetts it's established
about 1680 I lived in in Lakeville
Massachusetts we moved just at the
beginning of the poop hitting the fan so
we were fortunate to get into a new
joint we're real happy here by the way
he's Tom Curren of NBC Sports Boston and
you know I've done several of these with
general managers and coaches and I think
your background is the nicest of any
that I've seen now maybe the other ones
just didn't give a crap and didn't want
to put the camera in a nice room Stephen
Jones had it all set up with a window in
the background which made it look like
he was like sitting in a giant shadow
this right
high just a nice setup thank you well is
this a new rule this is here you'll like
this actually this is my grandfather's
hat Clarence Joseph Kilgallon 49 1907 he
worked for the Department of Agriculture
is it Vermont native so we got the
Edelman book that I that I was you know
living off the the Patriots teat with
good up James White picture we got a
couple of Emmys and I excuse to scratch
my back wait what did you win Emmys for
is this regional Emmy or national Emmy
can't even remember Mike think it was
international yeah why James White of
all the players past and present during
the patrons how does James White make it
onto your man it's funny because you
know the Patriots you know Stacey James
well they're really they have a hard
they have a hard shore ahead of them
doing media relations for the Patriots
it's not an easy job but they work
really hard to help us as much as they
can and they also do nice things well a
nice things that Stacey did one year is
he had one of his interns taking
pictures of all the media folk when they
were doing their jobs and at
Christmastime he he gave us these
pictures autographed by the player with
whom we were speaking so this is me and
Jimmy White nice yeah too bad you
weren't talking to Tom Brady at the time
it would have been a better picture
she didn't say that he didn't say that
to you he's okay
hey doctor I can tell that the pandemic
is taking a little bite out of your
doctor Robert Leonard experience that's
absolutely not friggin true look at that
oh not from that angle man angle we need
to do some work on the back he used to
look like somebody slapped me with a
slice of Bologna it was much worse all
right enough of all that
Oh first of all beyond the stuff that's
on the mantel under the man I was at a
working fireplace or is that just for
show it is working but it ain't gonna be
working for us we're gonna put an insert
and that thing yeah because it's propane
and my wife does not like propane I
don't like propane but you know what I
mean here's the thing about Freetown
Massachusetts Mike I'm gonna show the
folks we're really lucky this visit a
pond here called Long Pond do you know
what the difference between a pond and a
lake is I have no idea its depth its
depth Mike oh that's the break-even to
have a lake versus a pond that looks
like a lake there's a microphone there's
a microphone you need to speak into what
there's a microphone you need to speak
into when you turn it away I couldn't
hear you oh my bad um anyway tell me
about the pond it looks like a lake it
looks like one of the great lakes oh you
sure you don't even like a lady here
it's it's the largest recreational lake
in Massachusetts Michael huh it's a lake
not a pond
it's called Wang pond because pawns are
measured by depth not size it's only 10
feet deep and its deepest point but its
massive so fish in that pond you can
fish the crap out of it you can put
unlimited horsepower boats on it we're
gonna have ourselves a time out there
and I want you to come on up well when
you live outside of Boston Proper you
know how expensive it is in Boston
Proper you just take a 40-minute drive
outside Boston you don't have to live in
the city you're way away from the
pandemic kind of and you can have a nice
house on the water well it's nice of you
to show us around your house fairly new
house
gratulations on that bloody and let's
get down to business well first of all
how are you in the family doing through
all of this stuff really really pretty
good I think that you know everybody
relative to what folks are going through
I'm in the 99th percentile of good
fortune and you know even in sports
writing I think might you cover the best
sport there is to cover I cover the best
wood and the best team in the sport to
cover they are an absolute font of wait
wait I didn't hear you say you moved to
Kansas City no no the best team four
stories I mean I mean who cares right
all you want about Pat mahomes but all
the things that go on around the
Patriots
it's a nebulous font of storylines and
stories and it just doesn't dry up so
I'm really lucky I have like you do a I
have two kids in college one who's
graduating Sunday we will go through the
exercise downstairs in the kitchen I
have another one who's a junior who and
then I have an older son who's two years
out of school and you know I feel for
those kids I really feel for the group
of people from the ages of 15 to 45 to
50 it's a lot of sacrifices being made
by that demographic a lot of sacrifices
everybody's making them and we need to
well it's fluffy now you're right you're
right it's harder for the younger kids
that don't have the breadth of life
experience to compare this to don't I
mean they're on the brink of doing
things they really want to do and need
to do and all of a sudden pause has been
pressed on that whether it's school age
college age whatever the case may be
it's a sacrifice that for most of them
it's not voluntary because they're being
told by the grown-ups around them what
they can and can't do
I'm fortunate my sons been here the
whole time and he has complied with all
the various regulations and rules both
of the household and of the local and
state government which has been a good
thing because it would be hard I'm sure
there are plenty of kids out there
they're rebelling they jump in their car
and they go and and what's mom and dad
gonna do chase them you know I mean I I
suspect they're gonna be plenty of
stories of kids that just said screw it
I've had enough and they you know they
go out and they do things I shouldn't do
and it's at a point where I mean
to speak candidly about it and I know
that you and Michael David Smith and
Darren have done a great job I think and
you know being responsibly articulate on
looking at both sides of it there is a
demographic there that is bearing the
brunt of trying to get traction in their
industries and careers in their
livelihoods we're trying to raise
families and they already have a lot
stacked against them with college loans
and the job markets and the changeable
nature of things and then when we look
at statistics they aren't directly
impacted so you have to continue to
remind them of the ephemeral effect of
them staying secluded and isolated and
doing all the important things it's it's
just uh it's something man but sorry we
got way off track
ephemeral impressive see I'm used to
hanging out with guys like Chris Simms
who will just make a word up that he
thinks may mean something like what it
sounds like and it just comes out as a
complete and total mess which is part of
his charm
if ephemeral is one that you know I'm
humbled you breathe that in someone who
can properly use ephemeral you breathe
it in ephemeral let's get to the team
that you cover the most compelling team
in the National Football League I
thought of you yesterday when I saw Gary
Myers tweet I want to start there
Gary mark the NFL four years with the
New York Daily News he wrote the Brady
versus Manning book he's still around
the game he tweeted that part of why Tom
Brady left the Patriots was a
deterioration of his relationship with
offensive coordinator Josh McDaniels
sins and I talked it out today on PFT
live we came to the conclusion that
basically tom was weary of the entire
patriot way and josh mcdaniels is part
of it you can't have some of the Patriot
way it's all the patriot way that all
those coaches are like Bill Belichick
and if you're worn down by the way
things are you're necessarily going to
have deterioration with the individuals
who are imposing the Patriot Way on you
is it that simple or is there something
more to it that is specific to McDaniels
and brain no there's an element of
accuracy of the big element of accuracy
to what chris says and there's a kernel
of a root of accuracy to what Gary is
saying
however as I traced it with our folks on
our email chain today it's like Gary
just happened upon a airplane crash site
two months after it's been roped off
cleaned to document it and picked up a
little piece of a wing and said I found
it I found the reason you didn't you
didn't you found something that was
indicative of something bigger and the
something bigger seems to call it a
deteriorating relationship is sexing it
up was Brady somewhat marginalized in
2019 yes the why because the team didn't
want to commit to him long term well why
didn't want to commit to him long term
because of his age and what did that
mean that means he didn't get his
extension so when you're already feeling
that way and then when you show up to
work in July after not being at OTAs and
passing camps and finding out they
saying you know what let let us just do
the coaching okay we don't need you
directing the players and we'll come to
you if we need help damn we already got
the game plan in we can't just shred it
now and put your stuff in you start to
feel as if up okay I kind of see what's
going on Mike I had someone tell me a
few years ago well relative to quorum
Kowski that how I'm talking to that
person said that I know what it looks
like when a team when the team is trying
to move on from somebody and that's what
it looks like right now with Krunk last
year same person said that's what it
looks like with me right now so was
there a deteriorating relationship with
the office pencil Clerk no but the
relationship of the Job Description with
the team and so drastically changed that
he was off put by everything having to
do with work
you mentioned Tom Brady's staying away
from OTAs his last couple of years with
the Patriots on Howard Stern he
attributed that to essentially an
ultimatum not a heart ultimatum that he
got from his wife but a very clear
message that she expected something more
from him in the non-football months do
you buy that explanation or do you think
that staying away was some sort of a
middle finger the team sin seems to
think that blaming it on Giselle his
wife is a way to mask what was really
going on which is he was trying to stick
it to the Patriots by not
showing us again I think we're there's
some shades of gray there same way there
is what the the Gary Myers report
there's absolutely no doubt that you
cell must have articulated these you got
to cut the crap and I believe that was
probably after the 2016 season going
into 2017 relative to TV 12
Tom versus time and so many other things
that captured his attention so I
wouldn't be surprised if that happened
but also that Tom Brady decided to work
to rule doesn't surprise me either
you're gonna be making 15 million
dollars as he was for a large porch from
that contract prior to last year or
they're gonna be paying you bonuses that
you'll never hit because of the guys
they've surrounded you with and they
want you to come in work for half of
what drew Brees or Aaron Rodgers making
come in work for half what they're
making and then come in for free in May
June and July or April May and June I
really truly believe that that was a
combination I'm gonna spend more time
with my family because they need me my
wife needs my presence and you know what
you're not paying me enough when I'm in
the season why should I work for you for
free out of the season that's a good
point
I mean it's easy to justify staying away
from the team at a time when your family
wants you and need you and the team
isn't giving you a reason to say I'll
deal with my family they'll be okay I'll
see you on Monday for the voluntary
workouts now as it relates to Tom always
taking less money it's hard for me to
process him suddenly having an issue
with not being paid enough when he
consistently took less and I've always
believed he didn't consistently take
less because he wanted to leave enough
caps face behind so they'd have a great
team I've always believed he took less
because he feared Bill Belichick the
coach of the team and a guy who runs the
football operation waking up one day and
saying this guy's costing me too much
money I can find somebody who is dollar
for dollar better than him so bye-bye
Tom and her new quarterback how much of
that is part of why he always took less
great read by you
astha creamed and to back it up to
buttress your argument think about 2017
prior to Jimmy Garoppolo being traded
what is Seth Wickersham story do a very
good job of articulating that Brady
started to agitate in that offseason
let's get this extension because in 2016
he signed a two-year extension for I
believe 40 million about 20 million
dollars a year and he was looking
towards okay I think it was 16 and 17
was I'd have to double check it but he
was paying playing for less so when 2017
came and Jimmy was sitting there and Tom
was in a position where he wanted that
new contract which would be a symbolic
assurance that they were gonna move on
from Jimmy and stick with him and he
didn't get it that's what pissed him off
making it more exacerbating was after
the Patriots at least they never gave
and offered to Don you they talked about
them they tried to figure it out but
they never gave him one but they were
gonna paint Jimmy twelve fourteen
million dollars to back Brady up so when
Jimmy is eventually traded and Brandi
looks and says look I won now I want my
my raise you were gonna give this guy
twelve million dollars to watch me play
where's my raise that's when it became
not about playing for less it's you get
the dynamic of what I'm talking about
what did I just offered and he's at a
point where he no longer is worried
about Bill Belichick saying I don't want
you anymore in his mind if that's yes
thanks
somewhere else at this and he took less
in 2016 because Jimmy was still there he
had to beat back the challenge which he
did in the Super Bowl which again he was
doing in 2017 so that really is the crux
of it Mike he had beaten back the
challenge taking less I'm gonna take
less now
well once I do what I know I'm gonna do
I'm gonna ask for my god started money
and that's what happened yeah and I can
see that because I think his performance
in Super Bowl 51 put him on a higher
plane I remember having the feeling in
the aftermath of that game that he is
now at the Michael Jordan level even
though he didn't have six championships
this is a guy if he's anywhere within
driving distance or reasonable flight
distance you
need to go see him you need to be able
to say I was in his presence I saw this
guy play however long he continues and
here we are three years later and he's
still going but I gotta tell you this I
have to tell you this but after that
Super Bowl I was told specifically by
somebody really close to him now
everything changes I was like what does
that mean what they meant was he's
gotten to a level that Bradshaw didn't
get to that Montana didn't get to you're
exactly right the only person he would
have left Chase was with Jordan and
that's why 2017 and the Eagles Super
Bowl is so ranked ranked oh and I have a
feeling that when his wife joked about
walking off into the sunset after
winning Super Bowl 51 it really wasn't a
joke that would have been from a
dramatic standpoint from a presentation
standpoint that would have been the
ultimate moment to say see you later and
that would have been the most memorable
walk off into the sunset he may not get
that opportunity to win a Super Bowl
with the Buccaneers and walk off into
the sunset that moment may have been
squandered now it came back two years
later but he still refused to walk off
into the sunset how important do you
think it is to him to cap his career
with a championship and then walk away
with that trophy tucked under his arm I
don't think it's a priority I don't I
think the bigger priority is playing
until he did until he sucks and if his
last year when he sucks he goes nine and
seven or eight Nate and leaves the game
then he emptied the tank I can't imagine
him being like Jordan like so many of
the other the real greats
unlike a Barry Sanders who was a real
great medal just for good but Grunch him
what he did but Brady's gonna have to
have the game torn from his cold dead
hand and look that's the attitude a lot
of players have you rarely see all-time
greats decide they're going to hang on
as long as possible and I've wondered
from time to time
would Tom Brady ever continue to play
even if he can't find a starting job now
look this year there were teams that
wanted him but it's not like they were
lined up out the door the way right they
were gonna be it's not like they were
with Peyton Manning
it really isn't I thought it would be
but it was not do you think he would
still keep pressing to play even if he
was in a
Nutan spot where he's just out there
floating waiting for someone to give him
a phone call I think it would be hard
for him to do that
I really do especially at the age of 45
or 46 that's a difference between
Peyton's lying and the number of teams
taking a number for him and tell him
he's still 43 he's got a better arm than
Peyton did at 37
he's more put together and help more
healthy than Peyton was well probably
not in 2013 that's probably not accurate
on my part but Peyton had to leave there
was no more arm strength he got chased
from the game by his body
same thing with Favre we're not seeing
that yellow pretty Sims has always said
that Brady's gonna be able to throw the
way he currently throws into his 50s and
I had somebody who knows the game very
well tell me a few years ago that with
Brady you need to watch his legs yep
once he starts getting hit that's when
he potentially gets hurt that's when he
starts looking down at the rush instead
of down the field as we've seen him do
from time to time in specific games and
we've seen the business decisions he
makes now and look I'm not criticizing
him for you know throwing the ball
quickly and ducking and covering when
Frank Clark is bearing down on him and
missing Julian Edelman in the end zone
with the game on the line against the
Chiefs because you have to make that
decision to be available to your team
next week and if you take a square hit
from Frank Clark
y'all completing that pass to Julian
Edelman who are you really helping but I
feel like a lot of what's going on now
is self-preservation being factored into
his decision-making and that could be a
challenge with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
we know about the Bruce Arians offense
quarterback holds the ball a long time
no risk at no biscuit I don't know what
safe Tom's gonna have in that offensive
line sins and I were talking about this
today Phillip Rivers may even fit in a
better spot because he's got the better
offensive line what's important to watch
with Brady is he's actually attuned to
the time of year when he's gonna take
hits he doesn't take hits prior to
Thanksgiving he takes them after and in
the playoffs he'll stand in and take
ridiculous punishment but he does he
sees absolutely and it we started to see
that up here in about 2012 when they
played at Seattle on the road they lost
that you mad bro game there was a lot of
ducking a lot of ducking and running
and we've seen that over the years but
he still will answer a bell in the
bigger games when he knows something's
on the line but you're right it's it's
foot quickness which I still think that
he has and works on that's why he has it
to move around to be nimble in the
pocket but this past year there were two
things working against them there was
insufficient offensive line play there
was no tight end and there was
insufficient separation so he was as
unnerved as he's ever been and his
performance waned as the year went on
because there were too many times he'd
take the snap and say I don't think this
is gonna work out yep I've seen this one
last week and get out of here you know
he's got the weapons around him to throw
to this year without question Mike Evans
Chris God when now Gronk is there Oh J
Howard Cameron break I wonder if Brady
will have the kind of impact on them and
the offensive line and the defense and
everyone on the team will he kind of
have that Michael Jordan impact we've
seen so much during the last dance about
how Michael Jordan and look I don't know
whether or not Jordan is simply trying
to justify after the fact that he was an
[ __ ] an unmitigated unrelenting
[ __ ] and now when it's time to
package it up and sell it to a mass
audience it's being sold as something
that was strategic and tactical right
let's assume that that's what tom has
the power to do to hold guys accountable
to elevate their game do you see him
walking through the door and having that
kind of an impact on the Buccaneers I'm
told that this is what is driving him to
absolute distraction right now is to
gain ability to interact with his team
and make the cultural impact that he had
anticipated
you know people close to him that I
spoke to in late January when it was
being talked about it as to where he
would go and what impact he would have
he was wrong it was related to okay what
Manning did with Denver is what Tom
hopes to do and will do wherever he goes
there'll be a wholesale culture change
when he walks through the door
you can't enact that from uni you can't
you just can't do it
so they got to get their asses
stealthily up to Montana or something
caravan get get up there and start
working together because he's not having
the impact that I think that he hoped he
would have at this this time it's I
think it's robably driving a lot of
teams cuckoo but I think it's driving
him in his situation a little bit to
distraction don't you already wonder
though whether or not some of that's
going on like why does he have to be in
Tampa now he doesn't have to be in Tampa
now and that story that goofy thing
where he walks into the wrong house and
it's supposed to be Byron Leftwich his
house and he drops duffel bags on the
ground and somebody with another team
said to me those duffel bags you know
they didn't they didn't contain
volleyballs they got footballs in them
you know and he's working out with
Leftwich and he's meeting with these
guys and maybe he's meeting with his
teammates and he got kicked out of the
park down there
I mean look competitive juices are gonna
take over these guys think they're
invincible these guys don't care about a
pandemic they care about being the best
football players they can be and to hell
with everything else the risks they take
when they line up and play if you start
stacking them up coronavirus is going to
be very low on the list don't you think
that he and others around the league
have found a way discreetly to do the
things that they otherwise would be
doing during offseason workouts 100% and
I know that I would if I were in their
shoes it's it sure it's your occupation
and you have to find a way to do it is
it wearing receiver gloves is it you
know making sure that you can trust the
individual with whom you're going to
throw and say have you been quarantined
how many people around your house how
many people are interacting with you I
have family for instance I'm saying if I
was player what my mom lives with me and
the the room out back don't don't screw
with me you know you gotta be honest and
then you go do it I mean that's that's
part of what we're going to be
encountering over the next 60 to 90 days
it's the social contract that we have to
uphold and if I was an NFL player I
would probably go ahead and and do those
things because you have an occupation
that you have to be ready to perform
that does include interaction so yeah
yeah an easy thing to do would be to
take all these guys to Montana
way somehow I think once things start to
open up a little bit I know nothing
about the facilities that he has up
there but he's got the money to have
whatever he wants right of the most
recent last dance where Michael Jordan
is filming Space Jam and they they built
a facility for him there
I mean Brady can do whatever he wants to
do he can build whatever he wants to
build they can all go to Montana and
they can have pre training camp training
camp there with all the key players that
he needs to have present he can write
the check for all of it and it's no big
deal because his legacy is worth it his
impact on the Buccaneers is worth it and
I think we'd be naive to assume
something like that isn't going to
happen
it's a bigger and this is great having
the great times this conversation
usually cut me off by now but isn't it a
really interesting conversation relative
to the
one can't do it none can do it tenets
that the NFL is adhering to which i
think is important that they adhere to
but if you have innovative guys who have
the wherewithal to go to places and get
it done if they feel they are
individually safe and responsible in the
way they can do it and again I don't
think you agree with me I don't think
Michael David Smith agrees me I have a
different viewpoint on it but if you
think that you cannot put others at risk
and still take care of your vocation
should you do that
some guys will some guys won't some
quarterbacks will some quarterbacks well
everybody's got a different home
situation so it's fascinating is there
going to be an edict at some point where
Goodell says I you guys can't be getting
together in groups of five or more I
don't want to hear about it it's what do
you think Mike he's not going he's not
going to do that because he already
would have done that back when we were
seeing the videos of dak Prescott and
Dez Bryant they were posted in
consecutive weeks the story about that
Prescott having the dinner party at his
house his reluctance to acknowledge that
he had people who were in his home who
should have been in their homes not in
his homes the NFL has taken a very very
soft approach on this just saying we
encourage our players to follow the
guidelines when and it's it's amazing to
me that this is even controversial when
you have clear requirements clear
mandates from state and local
governments telling people what they can
and can't do in order to limit the
spread of a virus that will kill people
and has killed over 80,000 people and
Counting it's a staggering number the
idea that the NFL won't stand up the
idea that anyone they're not band-aids
well but the eye recommendations for
instance here in Massachusetts which is
very hard hit and is usually very
strident our mandates are no groupings
of ten or more or more well that's right
and in other states the mandates are
keep your ass at home only leave the
home for important essential reasons
like getting groceries getting
medication getting gas in your car so
you can get groceries and get medication
there's a very or at least has been how
it's it's all softening so much now I
don't know where it stands but there was
that period of time or
like I was living in the twilight zone
where governments are saying this is
what you must do in order to limit the
spread of this deadly virus and there
was evidence that NFL players were
ignoring those requirements and the
NFL's attitude was well we'd really like
you to comply when they have grossly and
excessively punish guys for something
that from the standpoint of what kind of
risk it poses to other people especially
on a widespread basis is far less than
what this risk is that's what's made me
feel like the world is turned upside
down and I understand they're finding
people out there that want to get back
to their jobs they want to get back to
earning money I get that but at least
early on in this when we were all
supposedly on the same page there were
these pockets of NFL players who weren't
on the same page you're right look I
didn't seem to care you're right and
that's the thing I think as we look at
this massive massive country with rural
beyond rural and cosmopolitan areas
where are the players who are getting
together are you getting together in
Dallas I mean it's a pretty you know
thick area you know if you were getting
together in New Jersey and be even more
insane or Massachusetts so it's just
this it's hard to and we talked about
Italy or Spain or Sweden or South Korea
and all these different places what they
did for 50 frigging states which were
basically some of them the size of their
own countries so I get it and it's a
conversation that just we could have for
hours and hours and hours I'm sure to be
a line of people who have their own
input on it we've been dealing with the
seven or eight weeks we have some very
embedded thoughts that we're gonna get
off our chest but in the long run I
think guys are gonna start to view
themselves as look I'm not personally at
risk of dying from this I might get sick
I might get real sick but chances are
actually really good that I won't get
sick at all for a couple of days and
then I'll be have antibodies and they're
gonna start to go out and prepare for
whatever kind of season there will be I
think was Kareem Jackson recently like
you guys plugged it up who said we can't
play until there's a hundred percent
until we've guaranteed 100% is no risk
not gonna happen it's not gonna happen
until that disease is eradicated and
it's not gonna be eradicated anytime in
the next 15 years
so and
I think you give some of these guys too
much credit when you lay out very
properly and responsibly the idea that
before guys get together they need to
write their family situations I don't
think that they think about their family
situations whether it's because and I
think it's this simple and I don't want
to make it a political thing but when
there are messages that have come from
the highest levels of government that
you can seize on too early in the
process and then plug your ears and not
listen well then anything else that said
those things that mess with what you
want to do become the thing that lets
you do what you want to do whether it's
just the flu or it's all hoax or it's
overblown it's no big deal you're gonna
do what you want to do you feel
impervious to it because look for most
of these guys who have made it to the
NFL they have already beaten odds far
longer than avoiding the coronavirus and
or getting sick and or dying from it
they'll take the risk that something
sims's all the time the individual
players don't care right they should
some of them should morbidly obese
offensive and defensive linemen should
have person who has diabetes should but
for the most part the average player is
like screw it I don't care I'm playing
football and I don't know that many
football players are engaging in that
analysis of how often do I come into
contact with Mema or papaw and what made
us do to them do i I don't want to say
most I oftentimes try and err on the
side of these guys are a lot we don't
give them enough credit and then I look
at the voting on the friggin a CBA and
I'm like why do we why do we get all
hyped up in the media about making sure
it's clear get there right cylinder than
any these guys don't even spend any time
studying like we who'd have no impact at
all from CBA do you ever notice that
Mike you ever think about that I agree
completely and let's be friggin crazy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports